welcome to division two finance
house bill 1462 fn
relative to motorcycle earnest permits
you're covered you're covered
would you
okay
sure
thank you mr chairman good morning
everybody representative len turcotte i
will introduce this bill on behalf of
the sponsor
michael jacob
jacobovic house bill 16 1462 fn
relative to motorcycle learners permits
anybody in the audience would like
testify
hmm
i do not know why
this
relative to motorcycle warner's permit
uh
do do you know why
well we're looking for all sides of the
i yeah there you go
got it uh larry crowe from the division
of motor vehicles uh the reason is the
current law only allows for one in a
lifetime it is entirely possible
somebody could get a motorcycle permit
and it could rain oh and it's only good
for 45 days
it could rain for those 45 days
putting people in a difficult situation
so this would allow for a
second time for them to be able to get
it
is that basically the only addition to
the bill or the only gist of the bill uh
to my understanding is reading it yes it
it just provides for that uh
that means um when you apply for your
first motorcycle permit you should be
pretty serious and
get it done uh assuming that your
motorcycle permit is intended to lead
toward a motorcycle license
that's your 45-day window to make it
happen
yes you can lose your motorcycle license
and you can get you do not have to have
a permit in order to get a motorcycle
license the motorcycle permit allows you
to
legally
operate on
the roadways of the state
the intention there is to a get practice
and be able to
you know
learn what you need to do and then to
legally get to the
to the dmv and test out however there
are other ways around it that you could
representative heath
and representative thank you thank you
um
in our fiscal note it says that this is
expected to be uh there's going to be a
one-time cost of 28 000. could you
i'm the motorcycle guy
i run motorcycle rider training um i can
however
you know
it does require an adjustment and
retooling of our computers right now
there's a hard stop if anybody's ever
had a permit and they come in and try to
apply to for another one
the system's going to deny them so
there's an adjustment to that i'm so i'm
guessing that is part of it i'm going to
emphasize that word guessing
and also some of our forms may have to
be updated and regraded so um it would
be
the the change in the law would require
us to do some one-time
work
thank you mr chairman thanks for the
question um i'm not going to ask you
whether you support or oppose this but i
will ask do you see this as a reasonable
accommodation
for motorcycle
i can tell you that um
in my office motorcycle rider training
we do regularly get phone calls from
people who have had a permit in the past
and now can't get one and are in a
little bit of a quandary as to where to
as a result of a time crunch and the
limitation of the 45 days yes some many
didn't realize they got one before and
this was oh yeah that's right or as i
said the you know whether uh
circumstances beyond their control
something like that so um
i do hear from the public that they
would like another shot at a motorcycle
yes you can uh um
um yeah yes you can uh let's go with a
scenario where
a resident has good considers himself to
have good motorcycle skills and does own
a motorcycle they can make an
appointment to
take the skills test
and as long as they legally get their
motorcycle to us
uh which could be trailering it there or
having a friend ride it then they hop on
it on our private you know in our closed
circuit
demonstrate that they've passed it uh
they're then good to go uh what can't
happen is they can't um fail the test
then hop on their motorcycle and we
watch them right away
that's uh um as i like to tell them
uh the written test is the test that's
representative
there definitely is another way for that
to happen and that is to go through
motorcycle rider training uh where we
provide the motorcycle and all the
instruction and at the conclusion of it
also administer the skill test which if
passed allows them to get their
motorcycle endorsement or motorcycle
yes
no we pay them it's a big responsibility
as the state coordinator of motorcycle
rider training i'm going to say that um
i do believe that is one of the
the absolute best ways to go ahead and
do that however there is the other
option which is absolutely allowed in
law
allowed in law
there is not we there are states that
are mandatory training on new hampshire
is not one of
so if we
pass this bill but if we first amend the
bill and take out the 25 at 28 000
and give you
permission to have the additional
permit time in place
um
how horrible would it be for your agency
no
it's not a budget year um so um would
you be able to go forward
without the 28 000.
yeah i i apologize uh representative
heath but i cannot answer that question
i'm just the motorcycle i understand and
when i say jest actually i think it's
pretty cool but that's okay i understand
i apologize i i don't have that thank
you
you notice this hair is all messed up
from riding his motorcycle over here
today it's a lovely day
excuse me and this is the permanent
anybody else
oh
thank you representative murray um in
lieu of the 28 000 um is there a
possibility what is the fee for a
motorcycle permit and to extend the
permit is there
would there be a possibility to add a
ten dollar fee or something on top of
that
um
again i can't speak a lot to the money
go around the um i can tell you that the
permit is a uh thirty dollar fee right
now which is i believe broken down by
it's actually twenty five dollars plus
five
um that five dollar uh fee does go to
help fund the motorcycle rider training
program goes directly to it um i believe
if i read if i read this correctly i'm
i'm not a financial expert like you
folks are but i believe the permit is uh
the extension is the same it looks to me
like another 25
and possibly the plus five
um
so
uh i'm sorry i lost track of the actual
question
yes yes there is the the renewal is not
a uh uh felis there is there is it's
just
it says in there that is revenue is
unknown because we've never done this
before so
it's very anecdotal for me to have an
opinion as far as how many do it we
could have a tremendous amount we could
have hardly anybody so i believe that is
why the the future revenue is unknown
thank you any anyone else
is the current
it went from 50 to 60. i believe that
was ten dollars
okay so real id is currently 60. okay
pardon
okay
and then it says
for each
use
youth operators license and examination
ten dollars per year
not to exceed 50.
oh
you don't
so
i'll try to speak loudly so everything
so everything you see there is not being
changed
so so what do motorcycle learner permits
cost
today
it is currently thirty dollars um and
then that thirty dollars
does
move pay forward for the endorsement
assuming that the uh the citizen
trent moves the permit into a
into an endorsement as a result of
successful testing that thirty dollars
goes forward
so there's not an additional fee at that
point that thirty dollars is pay early
or pay late but it's a one-time fee okay
so what you're asking for is that
if you don't
get your license within the time frame
then in order to renew it it would cost
you 25 more
is that right
as i read this i do believe that that's
it i don't see the additional
five dollar
fee in here
um which would bring it up to 30 but
under methodology it does say for an
additional fee of 30. so i believe it's
25 plus 5
and the 25 is for the permit and then
it was when um 263 334b was which is
motorcycle rider training rsa
uh
it was baked into that
that this program would be funded by a
variety of motorcycle use
and the license was part of that which
helps fund this
the program is prime is pretty much
self-funding by motorcyclists in the
state
so somewhere there's that five dollars
well it's not brought up to the 30
because it says 25.
yeah i'm looking at the methodology
yeah you folks are much better about the
uh i believe the five dollars is um
in on line 23 there's a reference to
original driver's license issues five
dollars is credited to driver training
that doesn't pertain to the motorcycle
uh i guess that as i look at this or
thought about it
that
since it's a renewal
you've already paid the five bucks
and so all we're doing is
renewing it
for yes mickey 263 34i
uh
says
okay
so
if i interpret this correctly what we're
saying is you've paid the five dollars
the first time
for your per um
um
so it would be 30 then it'd be 25 plus
the five dollars which is
assessed to any new permit or renewal or
license
currently for the basic rider course
which is the one we've been talking
about which leads to the possibility of
getting an endorsement that fee is 155
dollars
okay
sorry
i think the next thing on whoops that's
which is uh relative to
pfas
uh
oh is it is there a time it's two
o'clock
i know
sorry
that's all right
okay
yeah
well except this one uh
representative mooney's going to come in
and tell us there's no physical impact
yeah
that's a good thing yeah
that could be
yeah
interesting
sure
yep
um
i own two and i've been writing since a
teenager so
i look at this and i see this as kind of
like yeah let's just do it it's pretty
easy i agree
okay well then
would we like to yes mickey
yeah
i we're gonna have to get you a mic over
there
so just to clarify the fiscal impact of
this there's no appropriation here so
there's no new 28 thousand dollars being
drawn from anywhere so this would come
out of the department of safety's
current budget that you've already
adopted
so just so you know and 28 thousand
dollars in dmv's budget is not
substantial so i'm just gonna
just throw that out there and i can give
you their total budget if that helps but
i just want to clarify this was not a
okay
of order i guess would be more
appropriate
um
i don't know the answer since this is
classified as a division work session
can we vote we can
the only place you can't vote is
in the in the executive session we're
we're not full committee no we're not
full committee we're just making a
recommendation
then i would oh
can i make the motion
i make the motion then that we approve
uh hp 1462. okay otp
representative
yes
okay
so representative turcotte will you uh
write the blurb
okay
thanks
it's
god
see if i had used janet's
stuff i wouldn't have
okay
did everybody have a nice weekend
everyone looking forward to
yeah
i uh
i thought so
that's
that's three days when we're not
aggravating anyone out there other than
and on top of that we have a fiscal
yeah busy week busy week
i'm like
why did i
well first of all we weren't supposed to
meet tuesday wednesday and thursday when
we
we did
it's gone
i thought we it would be a good idea if
no that was all moved to monday
those
yeah those are the um
education bills that we have to uh
i think it would take too much time that
was part of the
that was part of the problem
that um
and i didn't want to have you come in at
two o'clock on friday afternoon
you know
yeah well that's that's what i thought
as well
so
that's why we scheduled that's why i
scheduled them for monday so that
okay
which is establishing the law
enforcement conduct review committee
in uh for the police standards and
training
and they are looking for an
appropriation
of
and they want to hire a staff attorney
represent welch would you like to come
thank you
madam chairman
for the record i'm representing david a
walt representative rockingham
kickstand and hampstead
um
i served on
the commission that crafted this bill
and quite frankly
we did not deal with the appropriation
the bill
[Music]
was largely crafted by
director skipper and then the folks from
the attorney general's office
so unless you have some questions that i
can answer
and i don't know if i'm not too good at
oh come on represent well you've been
answering questions for 30 years so
at least
in the in the legislature
oh okay well i said at least
at least
is there anyone here from police
standards
okay
okay i'm sorry mister skipper
i should have known that director
yeah
or at least sponsor willingly sponsored
the the bill so sit down thank you yeah
we're we're pretty informal in here
unlike um
what i would call regular hearings that
are are held over in the big room
um
we're in we're in the little room and
it's
so
i uh i really appreciate it and i know i
have met you before and i apologize for
not
recognizing you
uh madam chair uh we we've only met once
before and it was right after my coved
shot on zoom so i uh i might have
appeared a little foggy on the on the
screen
okay so i guess that what we want to
really focus in on um
i'm sure that all of us have read the
leak report
and are aware of uh
all of the things that
the
commission was trying to do to
sort out what's going on in the in the
police and i know that there's a process
right now that's going on
for people that are on the uh
i call it the lorry list which is not
the right name it's some esculpatory
something or other
and i guess that
i apologize oh that's quite right
um
it's
it's okay
um
i guess that what this is trying to do
what we used to do is we used to have a
little jar up at the front
our board
at the pilots union and whenever that
happened the individual had to put ten
dollars into the pot
and then it was uh donated
worthy charity i i
i absolutely am ready to pull the wallet
out but at the same time i gotta check
with the minister of finance at home to
see if i can afford that
[Laughter]
so as i read this this is pretty much
formalizing
what has been going on in the past
uh that is correct madam chair it really
uh while the title of this
uh bill speaks directly to the
misconduct piece
that
really the overarching effort here was
to contemporize
uh the business at hand in the business
that we have been conducting uh since
our inception in 1971.
so it really does kind of uh bring us uh
you know into
uh the present the present times
and including
that it also establishes this misconduct
review committee
that would be responsible for
responding to these types of allegations
okay
are there questions from anyone
because i do have some yes go ahead
represent murray thank you uh can you
just update me or give me a brief
overview um pertaining the
i guess or the not exactly controversial
but concerns about privacy and with the
list you're referencing about what does
the public what does the public get to
know and what does the public not get to
know with regards to a police infraction
of some kind well you thank you very
much for the question representative
murray uh in fact uh there has been uh
really
a significant change in that particular
area and it those changes have occurred
through legislation
the governor has signed a bill that has
already gone through to
make our disciplinary hearing process a
public process it's open to the public
documents that are presented during
those hearings are also made public
on top of that there was a recent
decision that was issued by judge
schulman
relative to a lawsuit that was levied by
the manchester union leader and the aclu
against police standards and training
and in that ruling the judge
really provided even greater guidance
with regard to
our responsibility
to balance the interests of the officer
versus the public
interests that would be attached to
whatever we were listening to in terms
of a hearing
there are certain cases where
a hearing which should be public and it
may involve discipline
would cross into those areas that would
be considered more of a private matter
let's say a police officer was arrested
for dwi
and in fact that dwi was really just
uh the unfortunate truth is discipline
uh disciplinary actions often are the
first signs of of a substance issue or a
mental health issue right
and it only comes to light because the
officer was caught driving drunk
so in a case like that uh
the the officer who is subject to the
hearing can
uh make a request to be heard in
non-public
uh to
demonstrate to the council
that
what we're going to talk about
really is more of a private nature to
include medical care
psychiatric care substance abuse
things of that nature uh also if there
is a an issue that may involve innocent
third parties or children you know we
would we would certainly look at that uh
and
and i'm sure the council would rule that
those are privacy issues that would
outweigh the public interest
now we also
are very ready to
listen to the officer and in fact they
don't
make a prevailing argument that the
privacy interest outweighs the public
interest then the council will go to a
public session
and certainly any documents that are
circulated during that public session
are made
you're welcome
go ahead thank you madam chair
i know due process especially under 91a
i mean if you're i know on the school
board you can ask for public hearing
but this almost requires a public
hearing i mean how do you how do you
differentiate that
that fine line
it it really is according to judge
shulman it is very much a case-by-case
situation and it is uh
it really falls on
the shoulders of the officer that is
subject to the hearing
to make a prevailing argument that uh
what they're about to talk about
should be kept
in a non-public setting
uh
and in
because this is so new uh
generally speaking if there was any even
remote
issue that we thought was going to be
private the whole thing was held in
private
and uh i should say a non-public you
know setting
this decision is very very new and in
fact
the law that just recently went into
effect that
demands that these hearings be held in
public
notwithstanding
the privacy issues
i candidly i will tell you that the
council is learning and putting in place
new processes we're very fortunate to
have
attorney stacy mosher who's attached to
our agency from the attorney general's
office
she serves as our
civil attorney and she's been
just excellent in terms of providing
guidance as we we kind of get our arms
around these new procedures that we have
and we are very sensitive
to the notion of due process to that
officer as well
it is imperative that
those officers receive complete due
process as part of this this overarching
uh
new way of of us doing business
thank you
representative bucco
thank you madam chair
um this proposal for one full-time
attorney and two full-time investigators
it's is
is there that much misconduct i mean
it's quite a long list of violations
here
i uh representative bucco i think this
is this is an excellent question because
uh the answer is unknown we don't know
what is going to happen
uh if this legislation goes into effect
and and the switch gets flipped
where we're going to be receiving these
complaints and
we
i have talked to
peers throughout the nation
and subject matter experts relative to
police investigations use of force
investigations as an attorney out of
connecticut that is really is a subject
matter expert and
and uh all of their opinion collectively
is that uh stand by because uh the
complaints are gonna come in uh
you know a whole lot
heavier than
what we've probably anticipated in the
first instance uh when the light shines
on this
yes and and
uh and i think it'll be imperative that
if in fact this legislation goes through
it'll be imperative for the uh the
attorney and the investigators to stay
true to
uh
those areas of misconduct that are
identified
and make sure that we don't get any
mission creep where we're we're going
beyond the scope of of really what this
committee is supposed to address thank
so
if i read this correctly
you want the attorney to work for you
and not for the ag as
we're doing right now
ah that is correct madam uh
one of the uh stipulations to form uh
this type of review committee which came
out of leak
was to make sure that it was
a standalone executive branch agency
and while
the attorney general's office also fits
in that same category
they have a very specific
responsibility to investigate
matters of public integrity where a
public servant would be committing a
crime
under the color of their particular job
to include police officers
and it was uh really decided that the
the misconduct piece and the criminal
piece should be kept separate
and that's the reason that uh this this
committee would be
at police standards and training
so
this particular lawyer would only be
dealing with misconduct
the way we see this now yes ma'am
okay and the two investigators would be
investigating misconduct only they would
be uh yes uh that is that would be their
primary function is to to investigate uh
allegations of misconduct and
and to be clear uh not only would they
uh be responsible for conducting
independent investigations but also
working with agencies that have robust
internal affairs agencies
example would be manchester pd or the
state police where
a good bulk of that work would be
carried by the agency
our investigators would work with them
to make sure that things are done within
the
parameters set forth in this particular
bill
okay
i hope you know that there are thousands
of state jobs out there
empty
so
um
what is uh
what is your thought process if this
passes
in being able to hire
these three people
easier to hire
identify an attorney to take on this
particular position
i will tell you candidly that
people who are going to act in the role
of the investigator will need to be
seasoned
police
leaders people who have sat in
command positions uh to really have a
very firm grasp of what uh you know what
they're investigating and the landscape
in which these things uh occur
and uh
so to that end it may be more difficult
for us to find
invest full-time investigators
nonetheless i do know that
new hampshire law enforcement
recognizes the importance of this and uh
i am interested to see if it does go
through uh
you know what what type of people will
be applying for for these types of
positions and i think there is a
tremendous pool of of people out there
just uh
encouraging them to to look in our
direction uh will be the
the difficult part as you know yeah
scalp them from somebody else that's uh
it's it's pure cannibalism out there
right not that right everybody's
stealing from everybody absolutely
um
i did not see an implementation date
oh there it is i'm sorry excuse me
so
um is the the 350 000
since this isn't
isn't effective until
one january
is the 350 for a full year
or is it really
half of that um
i um
it would be
for
uh the whole year and in fact
our thought process was to begin funding
in the area of november
and that would but you can't do that
because
it says the effective date is one
january
so you can't hire
people before
one general oh okay yes that doesn't
mean you can't go out and recruit so
that they could come to work on
january 2nd okay but we're basically we
have um
we have six months from january till one
july or 30 june
and so
i think
that our appropriation
could be halved or something
understood madam yes
uh and to that end um
we were trying to be proactive to
kind of get the roster set i got it i
got it so when the the switch got
flipped we were ready to roll so okay
understood so
is
i believe i believe that would cover the
so how much do you want to give them
mickey
yes go ahead tomorrow
when it comes to this is the
can the council absorb this cost now
without without having to
at the bottom of the line there it says
that it could be absorb excess any cost
in excess of the 350 could be absorbed
so that's why i'm asking the question if
the
program can be started before you get
this
uh
yes
i think
i think we could and and
it will
it will cause us to go back we're
getting ready to go in front of fiscal
on friday to to reappropriate
a number of our lines
and um
if if it was
this body's opinion that we should try
to fund it that way we would we would do
it
well just to follow up i'm just bringing
it up because this is the second year of
the budget and
we usually don't make appropriations
in this year
yeah i i hear you but i also know that
uh police standards and training is kind
of on the edge yes uh so i
i would
prefer to give them
some amount i'm just throwing yeah i
know tom not not the 350
but some thing yes
thank you madam chair i agree um
this is a whole new
being for you
um
and i
i would expect it's gonna require
who could be pretty expensive
yes ma'am um
and i would
this is a tough tough thing
um and it needs to be done well
i i think we all would agreed to that um
and
so i think if if
and you're those three the 350 000 is
non-lapsing
um i would i would also
concur with with the chair that i would
like to see something because i think
this is too important
um not to invest appropriately in it at
this time because this is a big deal
yeah so mickey the this says that uh
they'd be will they would have the money
to um
somebody throw out a number
well
reducing it you know what can i just ask
some questions you can ask all the
he's just he's just one of us lowly
peons
represent murray
thank you i have a question and just i
guess a personal comment if i may um
you referenced that you know you're
going to be dealing with issues around
substance abuse and some issues that may
involve children and mental health on
the council is there a place for a
professional a mental health
professional
to perhaps identify or help form a
conversation around some of those issues
there is not a specific person
specified under statute that should have
a mental health background to be part of
the council
we do work very closely and have
identified with
a
mental health
provider who is really kind of the
council's
mental health provider and in fact we
have engaged that doctor
in a couple of cases already where the
council asked for
some um
some further information with regard to
an officer that you know may be in front
of the council
beforehand to to maybe offer some
additional psychological screening and
or maybe some uh support
uh
you know that it's um
i i i can speak for the the sitting
members of the council now they're very
uh vigilant and
uh sensitive to
you know where we are with with uh
recognizing that
that cops are people
and and people have problems and they
need help and and uh
you know to that end
they've been very good about making sure
that those things are in place
while balancing
and that's the tough part is while
balancing accountability and making sure
that you know the officer is safe to be
out there working with the public and
they're they're not going to be a
problem so
and just if i made my personal comment i
was in a horrible car accident at the
beginning of january and the state
police were so fabulous and
compassionate and helpful and
professional and all the way through and
trooper gasek was my
was my buddy
and so just they were i just want i
would love you to know i'm sure you hear
a lot of negative things and i want you
to know how fabulous they were when i
had my accident i thank you for passing
that along and uh trooper gasic's a good
guy and i'll make sure that i i pass
that those kind words on
ah sorry about that yes
[Laughter]
as
chairman umberger said at the at the
beginning it's my understanding that
although this this bill
formalizes uh in a very good way i mean
i think i absolutely support the bill
um the
this the uh
this new process as i understand it
you know in a more in a in a less formal
sense
this is kind of what you've been doing
for a long time is that is that correct
and and so i just to sort of follow up
on that i guess i i wonder if you could
give us
some indication for example you you
referenced that attorney moser from uh
the attorney general's office is kind of
your
is your kind of contact person
so could you give us some indication on
you know say over
over the last five years on average
how
how much time have uh has an attorney
been involved in
you know misconduct kind of
investigations on the one hand and then
can you give us some indication of of
how much investigator resources you've
used on a
you know
on average in a given year over the last
five years excellent
so
to be clear uh my my second year
anniversary
uh
for lack of a better term a prosecuting
attorney for hearings right
in the history of police standards and
training that has been left to
that role has been left to the bureau
commander
for the standards
division within police standards and
training
and uh it has been um
a bit
colloquial for lack of a better term
right
we have relied
100 on the investigation that is
conducted by the outside agency without
review to speak up
or without providing
additional
guidance or
asking for more information we really
take that investigation done by an
outside agency at face value
our standards division will review that
case
and then
we would bring that case forward and
it's prosecuted by
major dave parento who
retired number two from new hampshire
state police and now
runs the standard bureau
of training
one of the things that was identified
during the leak commission and then
further
spoken about
on the actual misconduct
review
commission
was that the process needed to be more
adversariable
and that the prosecutor should in fact
prosecute the case
and be ready to provide a
sentenced recommendation beyond that and
i guess what i'm really trying to kind
of
what's what's the basis upon which
you believe that you would need a
full-time attorney
number one and number two what's the
basis upon which you believe you would
need
two full-time investigators in other
words that it
i i guess in some sense i maybe share
the same
concerns that representative puko
maybe expressed earlier is that is this
is there really that much misconduct
that we're gonna that you know you're
gonna you're gonna be able to occupy an
attorney full-time or occupy two
investigators full-time
or would it make more sense for us at
least initially
to you know
appropriate enough money let's say for a
part-time attorney and maybe
one investigator or even a part-time
investigator
um
with you know the understanding that if
it turns out
you're overwhelmed then you know you
come back next year and say we need you
know we need more
we need more we need more resources
excellent
excellent question i think that
as much work as there is
going into investigating this conduct
many times more effort
to review cases that are not going to be
looked at by this committee we're going
to need to have this vetting process in
these
i apologize are going to
um
really be
i anticipate it's going to be a a real
floodgate when this when this happens
people are going to want to file
complaints
that are going to be outside of the very
narrow scope that's outlined in in 106l
as proposed
uh
i i cannot tell you judge how what the
what the uh
the case load is going to be
uh the other portion of this is that
uh it is now incumbent upon police
standards and training
to review these uh
investigations
and to possibly have to go back with our
investigators to gather more information
in some cases there's going to be
agencies that will not have the
bandwidth
to complete an investigation on their
own
an average-sized police department in
the state of new hampshire has 10
full-time police officers and so a vast
number of them have less than that they
do not have robust ias
uh professional standards things of that
nature
they have professional citizens they
don't have a unit that addresses those
things
so
i i wish i could give you an answer i
can't because i don't know what the call
volume is going to be i don't know what
the workload is going to be i anticipate
there's going to be a lot of it
and i anticipate that a lot of it is
going to have to be looked at carefully
and a decision will probably be made if
this is not within our purview and we're
going to
we're going to refer this back to the
home agency it doesn't fall within the
confines of misconduct as defined uh but
i i just don't know
sorry no no thank you
are there any other yes represent
turcotte thank you madam chair thank you
for the question um first could i just
get your name again i missed it oh sure
a lot of people like to put an e-r on
the end of that but very good
um the question i i guess i'm kind of
going down representative lin's line of
questioning sure and that is
it almost sounds like you're saying that
by staffing these additional positions
we're almost going to be inviting an
may i make a comment on that
uh
sorry uh but
i have spoken to
my police chief not about this
particular thing but about the whole
issue of misconduct
and the problem is right now there is no
standard for misconduct in the state
and every single police chief
treats
misconduct differently
and so
my police chief may some send something
in
but police chief in
why
doesn't and so that's why
i think
that mr skipa is having so much trouble
trying to define
how big the pie is
i
if
if the feeling is that uh by hiring
these folks we're gonna invite
an increased call volume i i
that is not what i meant to say or
communicate
uh
really
i think that uh you know this was
carefully thought out during the
commission and
and we really felt that
to get this program started this was
really kind of low balling what what may
you know come down the road
uh you know with that said uh
i i just you know i i just could not
tell you how big the wave is gonna be
and
talking to my uh
my peers across the country uh they are
they're telling me that you know you
stand by because
you're going to be getting a lot of
complaints and those complaints have to
be vetted by somebody uh and then once
we determine that the complaint is a
legitimate complaint we're gonna have to
steer those investigations
um
i do appreciate uh
you know this different line of thought
like
well maybe maybe the floodgates don't
open at all and nobody shows up to the
party
and that would be good um and then i'd
have
i've had
i would have employees that i could have
do other things as well right
another piece to the investigator's pie
will be to help us conduct
compliance audits which are things that
uh we have
uh
it was identified uh in a 2019 audit of
our operation where we were falling very
short on
and so those uh those investigators
certainly
uh could
pick up the ball and and
also help us conduct those those
compliance audits is what we call them
just to make sure that agencies are are
doing exactly what they're supposed to
be doing
okay are there any further questions
okay now comes the hard part
i'd like to try to get agreement on
some number
and
i will start out
this is kind of like poker
[Laughter]
i will start out with a
175 which is basically
six months worth of
a lawyer and two investigators
knowing that
i can guarantee you these three people
will not be on board
on january 2nd
so there will be
money that's uh that's uh
left out of that
so is there
well we don't need to make a motion i
know i know okay is that right okay so
mickey
and
is there anything that anyone else has
to
offer or say on this
okay
so this will this will come back
thank you oh go ahead
okay
thank you mr skip i appreciate it so
much and uh
this this is really good work that folks
have been doing on
on this whole leak business and
i know it's going to be a process and
i'm sure we'll get more of those little
bills back in the future
thank you madam chair thank you members
of this committee thank you okay you're
welcome
okay
1547 which is setting maximum
contaminant levels
so
representative
mooney
has
good news for us
yes
i'll be brief and inexpensive that's
correct
that's how
go ahead thank you madam chair and
colleagues on the committee i'm the
prime sponsor of house bill 1547
and i'm distributing for you today
modified testimony that i gave to the
environment and agricultural committee
for the purposes of this division 2 work
session so i'm going to paraphrase it
just a bit
but i'm going to start really with my
concluding remarks since they may be the
most relevant to this committee and that
is i've been assured by new hampshire
department of environmental services of
which mr wimsat is here today to talk
after me that there are no fiscal
impacts on state revenues or
expenditures
additionally there is potential decrease
in expenditures for local governments
now for my bill
was replaced entirely by an amendment
so i just want to be sure everybody has
the proper version is that it is the
amended version it was entirely scraped
the original version to be replaced with
the amendment
the amendment does three things
uh the first is that it allows the
commissioner
of
the new hampshire department of
environmental services
to
initiate rules for soil remediation
standards
for perfluorochemicals
by november 1st 2023
let me go back just a bit this bill came
from a brainstorm session last summer
as you may know merrimack has faced
extraordinary pollution issues because
of saint gobain performance plastics
these
plastics uh chemical called pfas of
which there are many and they're still
being identified
have made their way into drinking water
soil and air not only in merrimack but
also surrounding communities
so last summer a group of legislators uh
got together and decided you know what
are we going to do what issues do we
want to focus on this particular
legislative session
so when it came to soil the idea was
that we needed a meter of what
constituted a pfas pollution in soil and
as we were discussing
we had certain ideas but then we brought
in
des
and they let us know
usgs excuse me usgs
which is the united states geological
survey is already performing a study of
new hampshire soil that's due by the
fall of 2022
so our original thought in the
brainstorm session to set these
standards was way way too premature
based on the study that's being done by
the federal government and that has a
due date
so the first section of the bill
recognizes that that the usgs is going
to be performing that study and that
they have a due date by which to report
those study findings
that's section one of the bill
section two amends the groundwater
protection act rulemaking section to add
soil
and to add that a person
which i'll get back to in a moment
liable for such contamination provides
safe alternative to water
to an impacted well
so if there is soil pollution found
based on the standards
that the commissioner said based on the
study that the usgs had
there can be a remedy there
we were assured the word person as
defined in the law
also includes companies
and public or private corporations
so that is section two
of the bill
then we get to lengthy section three
and i'm glad i started with the fiscal
piece because if you were to read
section three of the bill it would
appear
pricey
but in actuality it's actually a
friendly amendment that comes from
new hampshire des
clarifying language
that describes certification
requirements
for certain hazardous
waste generators this is going to avoid
confusion with those requirements that
are done on the federal level
and also maintain consistency between
our law and new hampshire for hazardous
waste generators and federal law
so i conclude my remarks uh having told
you uh the bottom line price
having also gone through the amended
version which replaces the entire bill
and i just want to make note
that this bill in my community
has been
recognized as almost um i hesitate to
use the word perfect but a perfect bill
in terms of the community working
together
with activists
our citizens for clean water state
legislators our state senator
new hampshire department of
environmental services
the environment and agriculture
committee approved the bill unanimously
the bill also went through the full
house
on february 16 2022
without debate and with that i'll
conclude my remark thank you madam chair
and members of the committee for your
attention and your service are there any
questions that anyone has
first representative mooney
okay oh
yes i guess i have to ask this um uh
thank you madam chair i guess i have to
ask this just to be sure that
um
where it where the when this is the
amended version by the way uh
two four two four four two four nine h
and we're um
exceedingly
i'm sorry
i guess i could
um
where it says
at the end of the fiscal note where it
says the exceedingly low standards that
this bill would establish
the costs would fall on property owners
village districts municipalities
counties and the state
is that all
um
been
well i don't know how it's been resolved
because this is amendment is the same
number that you're quoting here
so
so my my question is
um um are these
property owners village districts
municipalities comptons and state are
they gonna
are they gonna be liable for they would
huge costs
because these standards are so low okay
two things thank you for the question uh
first i believe the fiscal note's been
revised and second of all i know mr
wimsett's eager to address that note
that he himself worked on and that
should clarify thank you yes
yeah
i
up until up until i'm i'm sorry go ahead
there was huge costs because these
standards were so low so i guess
am i asking the question that you've
already answered
this this says the county and
state local
local and county governments may see in
decrease
so it went from these huge these
excessively low standards and huge costs
to now there's a decrease
that just brings up a question of how
did that happen
i'm going to pass that that's a great
nexus to
mr webb sat thank you representative
oh look at her sneaking out on that one
it's a great introduction
good afternoon madam chair members of
the committee good afternoon
if you'd like i'd be happy to answer
representative glucose question right
now absolutely sure so the original uh
version of the bill um although
well-intentioned proposed to set soil
standards numerical soil standards that
were exceedingly low they were actually
based upon the drinking water standards
for
for those same four pfas compounds
and what you know unless you're in this
business you don't know that
while drinking water standards tend to
be on the relatively low side in terms
of concentration because it's a it's a
direct exposure through drinking water
you know two and a half liters a day for
a lifetime
um
the corresponding soil standards that we
typically set for that
are usually at least three orders of
magnitude higher because they don't pose
the same risk in soils as they do in
drinking water
so like i said while well-intentioned
the original version of the bill
erroneously proposed to set those
standards to be equivalent to the
drinking water standards so it would
have set standards in soil that were
you know
unachieved not only unachievable but
probably
you couldn't even test for them at those
levels in soil so that was what our
original fiscal note suggested that
if the bill were to actually pass this
in its original form
it would create an untenable regulatory
situation that would be famously
expensive to try to comply with so
that's why that but but the bill is in
its current amended proposed amended
form or as amended by the house
would
okay are there other questions for mr
okay
um the other question that i had if i
made him
uh
is
i
i remember reading somewhere and this is
this goes back a while it may be a year
ago or even more that
uh in connection with what was going on
in in merrimack that
um
the standards being
proposed
um were uh way lower than the federal
standards and i and i guess what i want
to make sure of is
the
i under you you've given the explanation
for soil versus water it's it's
different but will the soil standards i
mean do you anticipate that the soil
standards that will
eventua that will
govern here
are consistent with the federal soil
standards
could you turn your mic on just press
the button thank you better doesn't it
yeah well
it works
yes so to be clear what you would have
read a year ago would have been
referring to our drinking water
standards and it is true
that the drinking water standards that
we set based on our own review of the
science
were lower than what was in place at the
time under the fed the federal the
federal government has to be said does
not currently have
drinking water mcl's that are
enforceable under the safe drinking
water act they just have what they call
a health advisory
they've basically said that for the two
compounds that most people are familiar
with pfoa and pfos
that a combined standard of 70 parts per
trillion is their health advisory
we were directed by this body by the
legislature to actually review the
science and
all the available science to date and
develop proposed state level drinking
water standards and when we did that
review
we arrived at numbers for pifoa and
pifos at 12 parts per trillion and 15
parts per trillion
respectively
and
i will tell you that since that time the
federal government has been trying to
catch up with the science
we're not sure what they're going to do
but the expectation is that they are
very likely to lower their advisory
and potentially propose a drinking water
mcl that would be federally enforceable
that will be much more consistent with
the numbers that we've already set in
state law
so that's that's where that comes from
as far as how that translates to soil
um again uh you know the we will we were
already about 12 months into our work
to begin setting soil standards for pfas
compounds and
we had to do and we have to do a lot
more work to set appropriate standards
for those compounds than we have had to
do for other contaminants
and the reason in part is because they
are
considered to pose a risk at such low
concentrations in drinking water and
when we set our soil standards we set
them so that the idea is we try to in
the first instance we try to assess
leachability so if you have a certain
concentration of these compounds in soil
what concentration will result in
after it trickles down and leaches into
the groundwater into violation of a
drinking water standard so that someone
using that groundwater would be getting
an unacceptable
dose of that contaminant
so that's how we landed those in but but
for pfas because the compounds are so
unique in the way that they behave in
the soil
and at the in in the fact that they're
relative uh regulated at low levels
we have to do a little bit more fancy
science if you will to really determine
what those numbers ought to be so the
first the the usgs study that
represented mooney referenced is really
a three-part study we're we've completed
the first part which is to try to get an
idea what are the background
concentrations of pfas in soils across
the whole state because we know that
these compounds have been
you know moving on the winds and
deposited on the ground from
precipitation for decades
in the absence of any particular local
source so we know that we see
a background level of phase in soil
around the state so first we had to get
our arms around what that was
and then we are now doing in the second
phase of the project where they are
taking some of the soil samples that
were collected
and doing laboratory studies on them to
see how they behave
we're looking at different soil types
because
while all contaminants move differently
with different soil types these
contaminants
are particularly behaved that way and so
we're looking at we for the first time
we may actually end up setting soil
standards that are different based on
the soil type so if you had a
a loam in a valley valley loam you know
you might it might be one appropriate
standard and if you had a sandy gravel
somewhere else it might be a more
appropriate a different number that
would be appropriate
so we're trying to do that work and
we're also going to because we
unfortunately have a number of sites in
the state
where we know local sources of pfas have
contaminated soils
we're doing field studies at those sites
usgs is doing that work for us to see
how the the known pfas concentrations in
the soil
are behaving and how they contribute to
groundwater quality impacts so it's
pretty complex and then once we have all
that we're still going to need to hire a
contractor to do some modeling to help
us develop those numbers so it's a
pretty complex business
but we felt that it really was the only
appropriate science-based way to set
soil standards that were fair
to the regulated community and that
that would be reflective of what how
these compounds really behave
so that's a long answer but i wanted to
give you some background about
how what we're working on
representative heath oh thank you madam
chair
um
many of the areas we're talking about
are areas are agricultural
are studies being conducted in relation
to what does it mean for the farms that
we have in these areas that's a terrific
question and there are both uh studies
in this nation and internationally that
have been conducted
a lot more work needs to be done
and we're actually considering some work
locally here in new hampshire to try to
evaluate that question in the coming
year
it's something that we've we've tried to
be as helpful to
we've had questions as you can imagine
from
you know local farmers who are
raising and selling crops to backyard
gardeners who want to know if they're in
the area where soils have impacted is it
safe for them to
grow vegetables and eat them and water
the vegetables with their well water and
that sort of thing it's been a little
unsatisfying for them because we don't
have really solid answers for them but
we're trying to monitor the science
that's being conducted internationally
and also do some of our own work to try
to advance those questions and get
representative murray
thank you
can you speak to the usgs study in terms
of the extent that it's does the extent
of it participating in new hampshire and
how you they would disseminate
information to local municipalities you
know should they find a uptick somewhere
would they contact that municipality to
let them know or the municipalities
already in the loop and waiting for
information
sure great question so actually that
first step um of saying we get we took
about a hundred samples at various areas
across the state and we divided up the
state to try to get
a good geographic representation but we
also
tried to look at various soil types for
the reasons that i described before so
that data
has just been shared with us i think
we're about to put that out on the
street so that people can look at it
understand that those
areas were selected purposely to try we
were trying not to
select anywhere where we knew we had a
local source of pfas contamination
because we were really trying to make
that a background study
now it has to be said there are parts of
southern new hampshire where so much of
the land has been subjected to air
emissions that there you know it's there
is a local source and so that those data
might reflect that um but certainly
we'll be we'll be communicating this
with communities and if we see anything
that concerns us we'd be reaching out
directly to those communities
what i think is more
probably
more more to the point of your question
is that when we identify a local source
that's created either a groundwater or
soil problem we're always communicating
whenever we identify a site
it's standard operating procedure to cc
the local health officer on any
correspondence that we make so that so
representative petry
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question now on these areas
where you have high concentrations
the remediation
probably is very costly if you can i
mean is that possible well i'm glad
you're asking the question and one of
the reasons that you know we're we're
really supportive of this bills one of
the things that it does is it directs us
by that same november 2023 date
to um
promulgate regulations that are specific
to pfas
with respect to groundwater protection
drinking water protection and hazardous
waste sites so those are the three
statutes that it gives us direction for
and the reason we wanted that is that
because these contaminants are
so unique but also because they're so
prevalent in our in our in our state
we felt we needed to be able to make
specific
regulations that would recognize that
feasible so for instance we have you
know
several miles of i-93 that is being
you know worked on in southern new
hampshire and they're no doubt going to
encounter soils that have been because
they're in this area of air deposition
they're undoubtedly going to encounter
soils that are contaminated
and what we want to be able to do is to
promulgate regulations that you know if
you have reg soils that pose that that
don't meet a particular soil standard
that we might set
we want to have options other options
available to the owners of those sites
to cost effectively manage those soils
as opposed to you know normally if we
have a soil standard and it's a
hazardous waste site we'll say well you
might spend you know two million dollars
just to take that soil to a disposal
facility
and in some cases well you know that
and
be aware that there are times when
even under the current regulatory
scenario we find
more cost-effective ways to deal with
the soil but with pfas we thought it was
going to be really important to do that
particularly to protect
not only the private sector but
municipalities
local governments that may have a fire
station that that has impacted you know
with pfas trying to give them
sort of i guess uh what i would describe
as
tailored ways to deal with soil
contamination that aren't
going to just be so ridiculously
expensive that it's not really as
reasonable so that's why i think that
getting this authority
clear authority to make that kind of
rule do that kind of rulemaking is going
to be really important to protect thank
uh
there's been a lot of money out of cares
and
arpa
that have gone to pfas
stuff
can you just give us sort of a
overview of
how the department is planning to
spend that money sure so absolutely you
know it's obvious as best i can so um
you're absolutely right the arpa money
in particular there's been uh you know
about right now about 150 million
dollars has been dedicated appropriated
to des
um to deal with both drinking water and
wastewater impacts that's primarily what
that money is is targeted for
and so we are um we have been working
mightily to
uh you know and that a lot of that money
is being
administered in combination with the
state drinking water and clean water sr
state revolving funds
so um there are a number of
um water systems across the state over
100 that will benefit from that money
not all of them have pfas contamination
but some of them do
and there i i'm afraid i can't give you
the i can't i don't i can't i don't have
to top my head to provide the numbers
that are specific to pfas but
there will be a substantial amount of
money so a community water system or a
public water system that has to put on
carbon treatment for example to treat
pfas in the drinking water they're
eligible for grant money as well as loan
money to to address that
so we have a number of you know programs
right now where we're trying to provide
as much
financial assistance to those
communities to deal with these problems
as we possibly can and that i'm happy to
say that in addition to the arpa money
which is essentially one-time money
the
bipartisan infrastructure law
the congress has passed
will also provide for the next five
years
substantial increased funding to the
state revolving fund programs
and some specific targeted money to what
they're calling emerging contaminants
and pfas is certainly in that category
so that amounts to probably i think that
is going to amount to something on the
order of
six to eight million dollars per year
over five years that will be dedicated
to water and wastewater projects that
that need help to address pfas
contamination
so the good news is that there is you
know it's a big problem but there's a
fair amount of money that's being put to
it to try to assist these communities
so
the the
the assistance will come through
the water and sewer projects that are
approved for dollars much of it yeah and
what what is a little different is that
we do have some communities in southern
new hampshire
or areas of communities that do not have
public water systems right they're all
drinking water private drinking water
wells
the good news is through a lot of
lobbying by the states and a lot of
people concerned and sharing their
concerns with congress
much of that money will be eligible
those parties who normally wouldn't be
eligible for the srf they will be
eligible if they are going to
particularly if they're looking to
connect to another drinking water system
or even stand up their own new drinking
water system to address those private
wells that have been impacted so we have
a tremendous amount of work ahead of us
in the coming years but there's gonna
you know if you were able to take a
future snapshot say five years from now
you're gonna see a lot more homes on
public connected to public water systems
in southern new hampshire than than you
see right now
so i happen to be from northern new
hampshire
so
overall i'm
not aware of a lot of pfas problems
up north
is that sort of a true statement
yes i think that's a that is a fair
statement when we you know if we if you
look at our map of impacts from pfas it
is definitely weighted much more heavily
to the southern half of the state and
that's
not surprising because it's going to
tend to track with
manufacturing facilities and the
intensity of commercial and
manufacturing industrial development
so
as a general rule the north country has
much less of that kind of contamination
than
it's not immune to the global impacts
that you know for that background i mean
no matter where we look in the state
we're going to see a certain background
concentrate a low co background
concentration of pfas just from
global transport but in terms of local
sources it's much less prevalent in the
north country than it is in southern and
seacoast new hampshire
okay are there any other questions yes
go ahead just one final question um do
you plot
cancer clusters
in relation to high impact pfas areas
well the department of environmental
services doesn't doesn't collect or
process cancer data that's the purview
of the department of health and human
services
and they are
working on and they have an existing
cancer you know
program that that looks at that data
they are communicating directly with
folks in southern new hampshire right
now because there are a lot of concerns
in those communities about the potential
health impacts of the pfas contamination
of drinking water that's that exists
there
but i apologize i probably told you
are there any further questions
seeing none thank you mr winsett it was
very informative and helpful and
it sounds like
you folks are doing a really good job
which
we're happy about thank you quite
welcome thank you
okay um
i was wondering if i could have
an otp motion on this
all right um
all right representative petra yes
clerk folks yes representative
yes
representative
okay thank you
boy we are really
moving right along here so thank you
very much i appreciate it and thank you
that's a good thing
okay
um of course we're on time it's now 2
30.
and
we will be uh
moving to
hb
establishing a
municipal road
and bridge disaster relief fund
so
represent aaron do you want to come up
for the record my name is representative
judy aaron and i am from sullivan county
district seven
which represents the towns of acworth
before you today is a bill that i
submitted
which
proposes to set up
a municipal road and bridge disaster
relief fund
in order to provide
gap funding to municipalities
that have experienced damage to the
roads and bridges due to a natural
disaster
my town was hit with
horrible flooding
as a result of
weather that we had
and there was significant road damage
and bridge damage done in our town
and i had come
to speak with many of the
house and senate leadership seeking
funds to help our municipality
work through
getting this damage repaired as quickly
as possible because there were major
roads through our town
houses and businesses
were cut off from being able to have
access in and out of town there was
actually
only one or two ways in and out of town
at the time
and what i was
told
by many people though there was quite a
bit of sympathy and desire to want to
help us in acworth
there was no statutory mechanism to get
money to us
in any expedient manner
and so
that's
where the idea for this
municipal road and bridge disaster
relief fund came from
so
i brought this bill to
the municipal
committee
and they passed it unanimously it is a
bipartisan legislation i worked with
senator khan
on it
and
we felt it was important to
establish this kind of fund
to help these towns
who experience this sort of devastation
and it was indeed devastating
we had
being
you know at the height of their seasons
not being able to have access to their
crops
we had
bascom maple farms which is one of the
largest maple producers
in the state unable to get to their sap
lines to fix them
and get them ready for this time of the
year
we had
farms that couldn't
get rid of their manure pits empty their
manure pits and uh that was starting to
cause a problem with um with them being
there was just a number of problems
utility poles that we couldn't have
access to because roads were so damaged
we couldn't get
any kind of equipment or materials
to do any kind of work on those
utility poles
so it was
imperative to have some sort of funding
immediately to get
work done on these roads to make them
passable
and seeing as we did not
we were unable to get any kind of help
from the state we had to turn to go to
um mascoma bank
and embarked on a 2.1 million dollar
loan for the town which we're still
trying to figure out how we're ever
going to pay back
this has been a financial
hardship for the town of akworth
it was also a financial it's also been a
financial hardship for some of the towns
surrounding our town
i know because of the
damage that was done to route 12
as a result of this
flooding and storms that we had
roads were diverted onto other roads
that really couldn't take that kind of
traffic
in langdon
i know that there was
i guess a south hemlock street
where
normally you get 50 cars a day
they ended up getting over a thousand a
day
which resulted in them having to
pay almost 28 000 a month in maintenance
to keep it was a gravel road to keep it
maintained so that school buses and
trucks could traverse there
safely
so you can see
the great financial impact that this
kind of uh natural disaster can
bring upon these small
communities
who do not have
financial resources
we had in our in our bank account
in our fund balance in acworth only 550
000 available
and um we only had
we were only able to access 350 000 of
that
to go towards road repairs
because we had to leave a 200 000 in the
and while we were able to use that money
it certainly wasn't
you know ample
funds to make the kinds of repairs that
we needed to make
but we used what we had available and
then we went had a special town meeting
and went to get this 2.1 million dollar
loan which we are working with mascoma
bank and
and so
that's
the
pretty much in a nutshell
why
i've come to you today and hope that you
will
be able to
proposed bill
and i'd be happy to answer any questions
okay represent petrie
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question was this con
was this declared a national disaster
this was declared
a
emergency
there was an emergency declaration
declared
and that happened um well i think it was
uh
three or four months after the event
happened
and
so i know there's a statute that is in
place now uh that says
that a town can loan money from the
state
but you'd have to wait until that
disaster
that declaration was declared by the
president of the united states
and i know that statute i guess is in
the uh
there's there's some bill in the senate
that seeks to change that
but um
as it is i mean
you know
we'd have to wait for presidential
declaration
follow-up yep
right and
that allows you to borrow from the
federal government doesn't it no no
allows you to borrow money from the
state treasury the state treasury yeah
but it's at a better rate than what you
could get at a bank is that correct
i'm not so sure i think i know the rate
that we got from the scoma bank was 2.6
percent
and
you know they were really really kind
and willing to work with us uh they're
even willing to work with us on a
schedule for paying the loan back and
the way it's structured is um it's sort
of like a revolving credit almost like a
home equity loan that as we
do a project we can expend funds from
that
and then when we apply to fema for
compensation
whatever money fema decides to send to
us back we can take that money and put
it towards
uh you know put it back into
paying back the loan so it's sort of
like a revolving kind of credit
represent murray
and this is maybe following up what you
just said so i understand you describe
this as gap funding
waiting for you know fema money to come
in
there's also the statement of
municipalities wishing to draw from the
fund in the future shall pay into the
fund a certain amount does this mean
that when the fema money comes in do you
reimburse the money this this you know
does the money go back into this fund if
we were to set up the fund no that's
that was not the intention okay so
so you would get money from the state
for the infrastructure in addition to
whatever fema provides well as i
understand fema will not pay you if you
have gotten funds from other sources
but you would lose your fema money if we
possibly i'm not sure but
what i
what the intention was this
of this was to do
whatever kind of temporary repairs that
you may need to do in order to get
yourself back into
working order
okay may i follow up on that somewhere
uh you certainly yeah thank you so now
you use the word temporary so this would
be getting roads at least passable yes
but then you would still need funds in
order to make the roads permanently
passable yes and where would that money
come from
well
you would then
have your projects
uh which you would submit to fema as to
what road work you need to have done
um and
that would be a project that you would
separately
apply for fema helped with
so you really want to know that this
would not disallow you from fema money
right you suggested before that you
might lose fema money if you got money
from the state well fema reimbursement
is never guaranteed anyway
so i don't know
what they would approve or what they
wouldn't approve
all right
representative lynn
yes i wonder um
have you um
had any discussions with fema about this
proposed legislation and how it would
you know how it would work with with
getting fema
funding for if in the event that there
were disasters in the future i have not
and and i'm going to ask
have you had any discussions with the
new hampshire municipal association
about this proposal in other words do
they
um
you you propose to have towns that want
to to be able to contribute have you had
any you know
inquiry of other towns how many would
likely be willing to do this whether
they think it's a good idea whether the
municipal association thinks it's a good
idea or not i have not heard anything
from an hma about this
but
i wouldn't see why
town wouldn't avail themselves
of a program like that if they needed it
i mean we have
there's a mutual aid to municipal mutual
aid
where towns pay into that so that if
they need help
in any kind of
problem that they have
say they need sand or they need
some sort of materials
the there is a
municipal
mutual aid
which works on the same kind of basis
you pay
a membership or some sort of annual fee
and you can then get help from this
mutual aid
so it's sort of kind of along the same
lines
right
okay um
just i mean i i guess one of the things
that
might be a reason that other towns would
not you know would
would not be interested would be if
if the result would be
a potential loss of fema funding so
i mean that's
i i i guess it sounds like they're
you know respectfully it sounds like
there really might be more work to be
done before we know whether this is
really a good idea
or not that's
i can't help but saying that at least it
seems that way to me sure um well i you
know in my estimation i just wanted to
at least provide some sort of statutory
vehicle where monies can get to the
towns that need them in this kind of
situation because there is none
nothing exists for them now
and when a town is hit this badly
and there's absolutely no way that the
state can step in to help them
i find it um you know kind of
disappointing that we can't do something
to help our towns when they're in this
sort of situation
jeopardize some sort of funding from the
federal government at least it's
something to get them
going that they can get themselves put
together
you know we had absolutely no resources
to do this we had people
contractors in the area
that lent their trucks and their
materials and said you know what we know
that you're in a really bad financial
situation now but we also know that you
need to get people on the road safely
and so we will help you and then at some
point in the future when you can pay us
back we'll be here
and thank god we had the goodness of
people's hearts to help us out
because we had nothing else
there was no statutory mechanism in the
state
to help a town in our position
and that's what i'm seeking to do with
this
thank you representative
thank you may i ask a series of
questions without asking for you
certainly
representative aaron how are you i'm
well thank you good excellent um
just a few questions i want to get my
kind of head around some numbers here
what's approximately one half percent of
your mean your municipal budget enact 6
because our municipal budget operating
budget is about a million three
this year anyway
thank you and what what did you say in
your town what was the total estimated
damage or what was the actual damage
okay well you know we've we've seen uh
damage estimates as high as 26 million
dollars for our town of akworth which
has a town of 850 people
and
the 26 million dollar
estimate
as i understand it was if every road was
made to
the way perfection the way it's supposed
to be according to
culvert size and
and all of the rules and regulations
realistically
what we ended up spending i guess so far
uh we have plans for around around 10 or
11 million dollars
in work
i know that we've spent about um
probably a million three or million and
a half
thus far
uh of our own money
and also monies that you know from this
loan that we took out so
um
we we put money into the roads
uh to fix them temporarily and now we
are you know making plans to do the
permanent
work on them
and you know we have a town engineer uh
we hired an engineer to work on all
kinds of uh
plans with and get all the permits and
everything from des and work with
homeland security and also fema to get
the roads back to where they should be
um
to this point has any money been
forwarded to the town on behalf of any
governmental agency fema
no and we don't expect to see any kind
of fema reimbursement until probably
late late spring
it
at you know
being optimistic
okay and my i guess the final question
would be
if this had been
in effect at the time
how much of your damage
would have been covered
under this bill
does that make sense yes well um i don't
know a dollar amount specifically it
would have to i would have had i would
ask have to ask that engineer who's
working with the town
um with regard to
you know what work
uh
they put in place i i would say at least
the million three that we had to with a
million four or five whatever it was
that we had to cover that we've already
spent
would have been covered
and it may have
made have prevented us from having to
okay um
mickey would you see if um
the fema guy could come and talk to us
oh
okay i'm sorry i apologize
okay so
could the young lady
thanks
oh we have two young ladies i have three
three young
lovely young assistants with me good i'm
sorry that's okay so hi good afternoon
i'm jen harper i'm the director for
homeland security and emergency
management so state fema
we're the good guys they're the bad guys
no just teasing
we're all good guys um so with me is
fallon reed who uh
is our special projects lead but
previous to that fallon was in charge of
all of our presidentially declared
disasters
currently we're we have seven open fema
disasters uh that we're managing
and
newly promoted as vanessa uranga who's
with us who took fallon space so they
are both the experts in the federal
guidance
so that's why i'll defer to them
momentarily so
um representative aaron was correct that
the flooding from july 29 30 did take a
little bit
to get declared although i have to say
it was record time for us that was
declared on october 4th
which is pretty unprecedented for fema
to turn around a disaster declaration in
that amount of time
that did get amended and the declaration
is now for the period of july 29 through
august 2nd and that was amended on
december 27th
of last year so we are
working with those towns in sullivan and
cheshire counties uh
pretty actively i have five staff that
are dedicated to just that one disaster
mission
and
there is as representative aaron said
there is a
currently a
exceptional disaster relief loan um i
yep so that is um looking to get amended
this session and that will allow
for zero percent interest loans and um
the governor to declare a state
emergency ahead of a presidential
disaster declaration
the word of caution would be there's no
guarantee to a presidential disaster
declaration so if a
community were to ask the state treasury
for a no interest loan
ahead of a debt presidentially declared
disaster and we do not get it that the
community would be 100
on board for paying that back at zero
percent interest if it gets approved um
in this session um
i think there was something else we were
going to talk about so i'm going to turn
it to balance
um
yeah so with the
what is 409 now when came through back
in 2017
required a presidential disaster
declaration and then the interest rate
was whatever the prevailing rate was
through treasury and as the director
mentioned those are the two things we're
looking to change uh 402 is also out
there which is to split the cost share
because fema disaster declarations are
75 25
split and the applicant or the local
community is responsible for that 25 as
it stands right now um so they're
looking to change that to
to be 50 percent of the state and 50 on
okay and so that is in currently an sb
402 correct
and then 409 is the one to modify the
exceptional disaster relief loan that
senator guida passed through in 2017.
okay but that's so that's law right now
409 is yes yep so yes so um
any of the applicants once we received
the disaster declaration on october 4th
could have asked for an exceptional
disaster relief loan
for
what they needed to make the repairs at
whatever the prevailing rate was
at the treasury at the time for a loan
and then whatever got reimbursed from
fema would the community would pay back
the treasury
um and go from there
so on the disaster relief side fema has
not
gone to the hundred percent yet like
they have on everything else this year
for covid we did um unfortunately for a
natural disaster to reach the threshold
for
to get 90 or 100 percent in new
hampshire it's
i think
over 200 million dollars it has to be
it's a percentage
there is some talk in dc that they may
be moving to do a 90 10 split for
disasters declared in the last year but
we haven't got confirmation of that so
right now we're operating off of the 75
until otherwise
but as far as this disaster goes and
then the one that was declared from
right before that as well because we got
hit twice in july
um
we did have the opportunity for folks
who wanted to do the exceptional
disaster lethal and they could have
moved forward with that if they chose to
but we haven't
done anything with that loan since it
okay
yes representative
thank you madam chair
um does your um agency take a stand on
hb 1665
um we do have some concerns with the
language things that you had brought up
before about how it would impact a
potential fema funding
especially if there are rules in
the
um
sorry the federal laws about if you have
essentially an insurance policy which
this kind of would be that that amount
has to be deducted from what fema will
pay you so
um any emergency work or long-term
repairs would deduct this amount from
that
follow-up go ahead so in light of senate
bill 409
is hb 1665 necessary
i think they come from two different
perspectives so
um
does as the director mentioned we would
need a disaster declaration
eventually or the state would be out
that money
the way i'm reading 1665 is that
this doesn't necessarily have to you
know just they'd have an event and need
the money from that
but it really would come into play
with how
if we have a fema disaster declaration
and the reimbursement there so
um i appreciate what the bill's trying
to do but i think there might be
some risk to
go ahead please
so if you have more than one question
just just go ahead thank you i got tired
of flipping on the mic
representative if i may clarify one
thing um so 409 is a loan
where um
it would be you know like if you took
out a loan from me and reimbursed and
fema doesn't have a problem with that we
actually ran the language by them with
that bill back in 2017. the concern was
1665. and i think you all brought it up
with that you keep that money yes and
that's where fema would say no that's
you can't have it both ways you know
it's either
something to get you through or they've
already fema doesn't need to reimburse
that because
um it's already been taken care of in
their eyes
a duplication of benefit all right just
yes please go ahead it is for you
can someone just clarify
you know you i got the impression and
you can correct me because it's probably
i'm trying i can't keep track of the
time
um was there a mechanism this 409 or
whatever was that in place that actworth
could have
taken advantage of that had they known
or had they chosen so that was available
to them which
not until we received the disaster
declaration
okay but this thing was in existence
that they could have taken the loan from
the state or once we received the
disaster declaration yes okay
which is one of the modifications we're
making in 409 is that the governor can
if he declares a state of emergency then
that opens up this path we don't have to
wait for fema because it is usually
60 days or several years yeah so there
okay
yes represent bucco
hey thank you madam chairman may i ask a
question of the lba you can ask anybody
you want in this room um
you know as i read through this
over the weekend i thought it sounded
like a really smart idea and i can
understand the need for it
but the the um
the
the fiscal note as amended
on
march yeah march 11.
the last the whole last paragraph is
about
how fema
none of the work would be eligible for
female reimbursement
with this
with a pile what they would consider a
policy
am i reading that correctly uh yeah and
this is something
that there's
made the whole difference i was thinking
when i was reading through this that
that when the female money finally came
they would be reimbursed
but this whole paragraph says no that's
thank you
i just wanted to add that
you know there if if we had money in
place right away
from uh legislation such as this
there may be that that that particular
road project would not be something that
we
would have to apply to fema for help for
we could take care of this on our own
and not have to wait for the federal
government to give us any kind of
funding or help
and that's kind of the intention behind
this
is
yes there would be work that we would
need to have done that eventually
you know we could
apply to fema for help for
but for some of the road work that we
could do we could get it done quick
right away and you're done one and done
and you wouldn't have to work you
wouldn't have to wait for federal
government to step in and do anything so
kind of gives us an option of divorcing
ourselves
from waiting for a federal declaration
and you know any other kind of
declaration and uh you know
doing going through the whole
bureaucracy of of working with the
federal government so
if if we were able to get funds right
away from the state
to get us
to get back into working order
some of those projects wouldn't be
submitted to fema
there would be other road projects
perhaps that would and because we didn't
receive any money and use any money to
work on those projects that wouldn't be
a problem and it wouldn't interfere with
any kind of fema reimbursement so that
was just the only comment i wanted to
make on that thank you
representative
thank you madam chair thanks
representative erin again um
you said something that you may have
already answered this
how many towns other than acquired
would be willing to
get into this type of arrangement
otherwise in other words
putting in one half percent of the
municipal budget has that been
i'm not sure i know you know new
hampshire municipal association is not
objecting to this and i think that
it's again it's an
basically enabling legislation if a town
chooses to participate in this kind of
program
they can and especially i think it would
be beneficial to our smaller towns our
smaller rural towns
who do not have the financial
wherewithal to deal with a devastating
natural disaster such as this
all right
and you know short of them getting any
kind of insurance policy i don't know
but this this at least gives them access
to state funds
without it being a loan that they would
have to pay back
um and
to be honest
if my town
took 6 500
every year
it would take them probably
40 years before they would amass any
kind of money that would really make a
difference to help them in this kind of
situation and when you take a take a
look at say crane brook road alone
three and a half miles
which we had finished paving
like two or three years prior to this
happening
that our town
had so much uh
saved and and and
worked so hard so that they could at
least pave this one road for three and a
half miles and then in one night it was
completely gone
so you know
small towns like ours we take years and
years and years to invest in these
infrastructures
and in the in the space of an evening
it's completely gone
representative petry oh i'm sorry did
you have another
okay
maybe somebody in the back can answer
does insurance even exist for something
like this
go ahead thank you madam chair
thank you for taking my question uh
you don't have any capital reserve funds
to uh cover some of this
we do we use them all i mean
we we used uh fifty thousand dollars
from our bridge fund
to get we have
uh one bridge that the whole
underneath there's a slab on top and the
hole underneath of an and a culvert it's
a big culvert with a slab on top and the
whole underneath of it was washed away
so what we use this fifty thousand
dollars for
was basically to have somebody come in
and
blow in concrete underneath it to shore
it all up
but that's a temporary fix
you know to replace this bridge is going
to be like two million dollars
how does our town come up with that kind
of funding we we we have to we my town
has to come up uh what's uh follow a
question uh what's the town worth
ah
i don't know roughly i mean
i don't know 500 million probably
i don't know off the top of my head
because usually you know yeah i don't
know
well functioning a budget let's just say
the 2.1 million dollars that we borrowed
was the limit that we could get because
of what our town valuation was
we couldn't borrow any more
thank you
oh are you from nhma no you know oh did
you have another
oh okay
uh the faces at nhma have changed so
rapidly
in the last three months that i have no
idea who anyone is
in any please come up
and
the the same thing happened
hello i'm katherine heck i'm the
government finance advisor at nhma and
for those who agck heck like what the
heck
and for those who knew barbara reed that
is the job that i have taken over for i
joined in august so there's two of us
that are new so um
so did you have any specific questions
for us um we didn't oppose this
legislation as it's enabling
we felt that if a municipality felt as
though they really wanted to kind of buy
into this type of what i would call
insurance policy for
potentially a gap
that has been addressed by
representative aaron if that they feel
that's in the best interest of their
community
we certainly wouldn't want to stop them
we have no feedback or input onto how
many communities would take advantage of
this
their particular situation was
catastrophic in my professional opinion
our hundred-year storms are happening
more and more often um so some
communities are able to
move forward with fund balance capital
reserves and some type of bank loan
before fema can come in or potentially a
bond if fema wouldn't be approved
so we can't really speak to what the
future holds for
this type of this type of event but we
certainly wouldn't want to prohibit a
municipality from
this type of option should have become
available
represent lynn go ahead i'm sorry um we
heard from from the fema people just now
that there's not
the towns can't get
insurance for this kind of thing i'm
just kind of i'm just wondering
would this be something that if let's
assume that a lot of towns decided they
want they did want to take advantage of
this and they joined into it
would this be something
if they did that under the auspices of
fee of new hampshire municipal
association
is this the kind of thing that
nhma could get some kind of reinsurance
for that you would say you know
okay we're gonna
we're going to have to pay out we under
we anticipate that we're going to have
to pay out you know every year or every
few years for somewhere in the state
there's going to be some kind of a
disaster
we'll we'll have to pay out but we
you know we have gotten some reinsurance
through some insurance company or
whatever to be able to reimburse you
so that's a great question and that
would be for primex we are not part of a
risk pool any longer nhma primex is now
um
the municipal insurance company that's a
separate entity from nhma as of 2009 or
10 i believe
so
we wouldn't engage in that type of
reinsurance because we're not in that
industry but primex would be someone
that potentially could answer that
question however to my knowledge that is
not something the risk pool provides
otherwise and and maybe fema could speak
to this otherwise i believe that would
be something that would be offered
already in the industry okay
all right thank you you're welcome
are there any other questions yes rip
some teeth um these
issues are not new i mean um
that corner of new hampshire actually i
think it was like in 2007 maybe
um experienced
um a really horrible horrible
event i i remember um
the governor was there and it just
it's like everything washed away um what
did they do then
um
how how do municipalities deal with um
that kind of an impact
so that they can get up and running just
well enough until fema or somebody else
can come in and do the heavy duty work
yeah so i think you're referring to what
they call the mother's day floods yes
just exactly that's right here to new
hampshire from new york city and
wondered what i was doing exactly
um yeah with a trailer and three small
children
so
in some cases when in that case i think
it was many state roads that that were
the issue and i know the state had to
come in and when it came to the town
roads fema also did did come in and help
us in my own town included and since
then there have been incidences on a
smaller scale and either the town has to
have fund balance or capital reserves or
they have to go to bond um if it doesn't
you're welcome
are there any further questions oh
i'm sorry
this is this is in relation to what if
so what if new hampshire took some of
that
rainy day fund that it has in place and
said we're going to put 50 million
dollars in a pot
in the event of
disaster but
the towns and municipalities would take
it as a loan
and would have to pay it back
unfortunately
that money has to be
expense would which is it rick uh mickey
by 2026 so that that's not even a
no she's talking about from arpa oh no
no i'm talking about the rainy day oh
okay
he heard me right oh okay i heard you're
wrong
all right
all right thank you thank you
i have enough stuff on fiscal thank you
[Laughter]
are there any other questions
thank you very much thank you nice to
meet you all nice meeting you and uh and
welcome
uh i'm sure we'll be seeing you at least
around the hallways
if not uh enjoying a visit with us so
thank you
okay
okay i need to do some thinking about
this bill
uh
we also
i think need to read
uh 21p colon 37
which is that sb 409
and i think we also need to look at sb
which is the bill that's i don't know if
it's past the senate or
sure
yes so i was to the hearing for sb 402
and i think and it's still in committee
it hasn't been voted out of committee
the finance committee of the senate yet
and um
the problem that they had with that bill
was that
so that that bill provides for the state
to pick up 12 and a half percent and the
municipality to pick up 12 and a half
percent of the 25 that's matched with
fema
and the problem that they had with that
at least what senator chuck morris was
expressing was that they had no idea of
how much money 12 and a half percent
represented in terms of
what they would have to as a senate
finance committee
set aside for an appropriation from the
state
because
there there was no number
of how much
money
individual municipalities was going to
claim
to fema for their projects
so they had no
no idea
what that 12 and a half percent
represented
so that's why this bill is kind of just
sitting there in finance right now they
haven't made a decision
and i guess they're trying to get more
information about what 12 and a half
percent would equate to from from
uh state
allocation do you have like a five-year
average of fema
that you could
uh give us some sort of indication as to
yeah
okay
oh i don't need you to go back that far
yeah if if you could just give us
something that would um
estimate what that sure i can send that
to mickey and we've also um with senator
khan have provided some information
about
their going off of
a little disaster history or education
for you is when we do the preliminary
damage assessments with fema that gives
us the initial amount to say to the
president we've hit this threshold and
so
the last um time we met and
if i'm wrong but they based the numbers
off of that about six and a half million
or so
which we think will likely be higher but
we don't know but also
just this week we heard that they're in
dc trying to work towards a 90 10 split
so some information came out this week
that might help out
with 402 so but yes we i can provide the
last few disasters information to yeah
it would be good over like a couple
years anyhow a couple three years
because it's uh
you know disasters vary from year to
year yeah absolutely in
the southwest corner
doesn't get hit often but when they do
it it's pretty big so yeah yeah yeah and
i and i i
know that in that area
that uh
representative aaron is talking about
the majority of the damage was not to
state roads
yeah it was to uh local roads which um
you know
i think the state
did all the work on the state roads
but um yeah and back in 2005 2006 2007
we had three consecutive years of storms
the alstead mother's day and then the
october storms as well in um similar
situation and that's where the split 12
and a half split came from and so from
2005 disasters to 2011 the state paid
that 12 and a half percent and it went
away in 2011 um but that came as a
direct result of those disasters that it
hit
because the state roads had hit a lot
but boston was like wiped off the map
in addition to some other communities so
the good news is all the mitigation work
that we did after that
held up and hasn't been re-impacted but
to get there takes a little bit so and
i understand fema will
support mitigation efforts yup yup we
have a whole mitigation program at our
office that works with fema
there's additional funding for
mitigation that was not disaster
impacted so we have several
opportunities for funding but with a
disaster declaration they look at
two kind of phases getting the
facility the roads in this case back to
like day before storm level and then
we'll also look at mitigation to improve
it to make it so it doesn't happen again
i mean that's all under done under
public assistance and then we have our
mitigation program that looks at
primarily non-disaster
or impacted things and affects that as
well that you can have been in a blue
sky day or fix in a blue sky day rather
so yeah we have lots of funding
opportunities yeah we're looking for
money
up in uh
north conway yeah for uh saco river that
doesn't know where it wants to go
changes on the daily yeah it you know
she talked about blue sky
you know what what what the soccer was
like yesterday
is not the same as it was the day before
or the day after so yeah
oh yeah it's
you know
they've talked about meandering
rivers
i don't know what this does but it
certainly
doesn't stay anywhere near its own path
yeah the suncook river completely
changed direction a number of years ago
and that a large yep yep that was a
large mitigation project that we did
there as well with fema so
yeah this one the the is eating our
hungry yeah
yeah
what the heck
anyhow we'll keep smiling and um
i guess uh if there's nothing else we
will meet again on
monday
i believe it's at ten o'clock
is that right
yes
three we have three education bills
and um
to look at
and then we uh on uh
wednesday of next week will be the
executive session so we'll
if anybody has anything um
on these three education bills that
they think will need an amendment well
we'll need to
get that moving
um
i'm considering that we may make a small
allocation
uh in the same way that we
did
with the police standards uh and maybe
give them uh
six months worth of
but that's i you know
that's that's not up to me that's
up to
you
okay
so in that case
we'll see you
tomorrow
10 o'clock
you